hey everyone
thought it would be important to
comment given today's landscape
of technology
in the way that it is so deeply
interconnected with our lives
first i would like to say that
if you've ever been an entrepreneur or
you are an entrepreneur
you are much more likely to
have a deeper amount of understanding
of what the biggest
fortune 500 ceos are actually going
through
it's easy to critique people
when you have never actually
even operated a business
so first of all
get behind their perspective in their
eyes
as we aim to architect a better
future it's important to take the moment
to actually understand who
these big tech founders are
and their trajectories of how they
even got to where they're at today
their stories are very important
about how they got where they are today
actually in many ways
their stories serve as the inspirational
material
for the next generation of
founders that are 20 years old
to make the future
and build it happen
it's critical so first of all take that
moment
to more deeply understand truly
what it's like to both operate at that
level and to have
that many people that your company
directly affects every single day and
also the trajectory of what it takes to
get there so first of all that
second of all i'd like to point out how
peter thiel is famous for saying this
that if you are a monopoly
the number one thing you need to do is
absolutely deny
that you are a monopoly so similar with
rockefeller and carnegie
is same thing that's going on right now
with
amazon facebook
uh microsoft google apple
the biggest tech giants in the us
and the biggest tech giants in china
there's a big difference here that we'll
talk about in a moment
but their number one objective is to
literally vehemently deny that they are
monopolies
no matter what at all costs
as because as soon as you would say that
yeah actually given
this specific niche of the sector we
absolutely have a monopoly is a
plummeting of the value of your
organization
but all of them have embedded growth
obligations
egos ego embedded growth obligation eric
weinstein's been very passionate about
teaching us about that
and it's very true that even given back
a hundred years ago
henry ford whoever you want to pick all
just had embedded growth obligations
they need to sell as much
of what they are as possible to the
world period
and we need to collectively realize that
it's actually potentially better
to have different architectures
in order for us to succeed with
different styles of creativity
entrepreneurship combinatorics to
achieve these biggest goals
rather than specifically basically not
giving a [ __ ]
how we get to our end objective whatever
that telos may be
but likely recursive
but this is a very important point to
keep in mind
that if we are going to be serious
about the way that fortune 500 companies
affect especially in the technology age
our lives
we need to take a deeper perspective
on what's actually going on and the same
thing is true right now
let's go to this point with the us and
china quick
one thing to absolutely embed and never
forget
is that we live
in a country in the united states
where even in just the last
less than 250 years we have maintained
some sort of a code of law
which makes it so that the biggest
technology companies
in the world have to have
a congressional hearing
just let that sink in for a moment the
fact that we even have
open dialogue between
our government and technology
committees and anti-trust laws
the fact that we even have that and that
these tech ceos have to attend and have
to have discourse
is extremely important so never forget
that we actually
have that that is very important to
remember
that is literally dialectic that is the
discourse
that the united states is famous for the
fact that we can actually
get the biggest companies
to come and speak to congress about the
future trajectory
of what's going on now whether or not
actually breaking them up like we did
with rockefeller
and oil and is a good idea or not
is extremely complicated and
we don't even know the downstream
effects of such things
we know that what happened with
rockefeller is now we have a bunch of
massive oil companies that are still
flourishing
today now should they be innovating into
fields like nuclear fusion at faster
rates absolutely
is the same true if you broke up
facebook or apple or amazon or google
that they're that the little broken up
subsidiaries would after a period of
5 10 25 years even still
be around or not who knows is it better
to do so very complicated
this is where a center for for economic
simulation would actually be a very good
choice
i've been talking about this quite a bit
and i try talking
at a deeper level with andrew yang about
this it's very important
a center for economic simulation cfes
and what you would do with that is you
would do things like try to model it out
what would happen to the united states
economy if you were to break up an apple
or a facebook or
google or an amazon what would actually
happen
and you can actually create simulations
economic simulations of these things
just like you could create an economic
simulation if you taxed
every single wall street transaction at
half a percent
what would happen where could you
allocate that money would it would it
can
would people continue doing wall street
transactions given that extra tax
and then would you be able to allocate
that extra percent half a percent to
education to spirituality and science
training programs um for those that are
under-resourced
especially as children across the united
states so
these are the important ways to perceive
reality and how you can actually at a
deeper level
push for people to run these styles of
economic simulations
which then give us deeper insight into
what we can do to maximize our
collective potential
now let's just juxtapose what we just
described with the united states with
china
as an example if you take china
and the way that china's moving forward
china is doing things like
they have a direct relationship between
their government and their technology
companies
where it's all under one cohesive
strategic roof now
it's complicated it's not as simple as
saying this is binary better than that
period end of story it's not that simple
when you do things like you take
somebody in the united states
that owns a piece of land that they
absolutely refuse to sell that piece of
land meanwhile
we are trying to build a
a um maybe an
autonomous pathway for vehicles
through that area china is able to say
that
we are sorry but we are going to build
this
autonomous pathway through your land but
in the united states
you can just sit your ass on that land
and not
budge and so you have to realize that
there are
these interesting ideas of the
individual and the collective that need
to be harmonized at a greater level
so the fact that the us has a very
specific style of handling the tech
giants with the congress
versus the government handling the tech
giants in a place like china and by the
way go look at saudi arabia go look at
russia go look at brazil go look at
india go look at germany
go look at ethiopia go look at other
countries around the world it's
not just the difference between the
united states and china although those
are the two
absolute greatest economic powers but
you do have to do these
run these combinatorics what could the
united states
government and their relationship with
tech ceos learn
from an example let's say the
relationship that the indian government
has with their largest technology
companies
it's extremely hubristic to believe that
we have absolutely nothing to learn from
the other little combinatorics of how
governments
and corporations interact across the
planet and it's also hubristic for them
to believe that they have nothing to
learn from the united states
so again it's all about that cohesion
and an understanding and a balancing
of the beauty of diversity in oneness
at the same time right simultaneity
being that key
ultimately it's about these data silos
as well we have to remember that
at the end of the day it's going to be a
opening of the data silos it's going to
be an inclusive
stakeholding as well so the fact that
the existing social fabric has
absolutely no inclusive stakeholding
ownership is extremely non-biomimicry
and because of that we're experiencing a
lot of the
issues given wealth inequality
given the absolute extreme allocation of
all new income to the top one percent
the absolute best way to handle that
specific scenario is crystal clear and
it's the exact same way that natural
systems have biomimicry
so you take the way that large trees
sequester carbon and distribute it
through their root and fungal networks
to seedlings
and smaller trees that exact same style
of strategy
enabling through inclusive stakeholding
the fact that you have all of your data
with amazon with apple
with microsoft with google with facebook
with
tesla with all these major big companies
in the united states
you absolutely and all of us deserve at
a deeper level to have
new economic styles flourishing which
take all of our data give us
a deeper amount of financial ownership
over that data and inclusive
stakeholding over that data
but also drop the silo so that we can
more easily find
unique insights in the data across the
big companies for our own
avatar profiles but also for them
to be able to find deeper insights onto
how to harmonize
on a collective level rather than on
such an individual closed off siloed
level
that is absolutely the future trajectory
that we are heading towards
again inclusive stakeholding and opening
up the data silos
critical point it's a central part of
the thesis of
the big synthesis that will we are
publishing
all right let's transition to tick tock
extremely important news with that
as you guys know tik tok is the absolute
it's eating the world
especially the youth and what's going on
is that you have this extremely
short form video platform full screen
beautiful user experience and design
that is captivating and the loops are
super
tight on our neuroscience on our
neurobiology they're just really tight
loops
that as soon as you kind of get on the
platform it's really difficult to get
off because
everything is so unique and creative and
it's
humans expressing themselves in creative
ways and it's fun
and it really easily deters us though
and deters our long periods of deep work
and focus
again cal newport deep work that's
really important for you to get your
north star accomplished
but also we get these unique little
combinatorics while humans are being
created around the world and we get to
watch this little tick tock
pop up from different countries around
the world it's actually quite
interesting
as you guys know it's also right now at
the top
of the most valuable privately owned
companies in the world
ranges from 50 billion to a hundred
billion dollar valuations
extremely interesting how there was also
the merger
of what was bite dances companies
with musically in the us and then how
that ended up turning into
this global behemoth that we have today
of tick tock and how india took a step
forward and said that we must ban this
because we don't trust which is very
very crazy and it's fascinating that
that type of stuff is happening
and the same thing with the united
states stepping up and saying that
no we also don't trust the fact that
we don't trust each other across the
planet is actually
extremely deteriorating for our spirit
collectively it's extremely
deteriorating we will only
figure this out at a deeper level within
the next couple of years and decades
when we realize how much we don't trust
one another
and how moving forward we are going to
have to trust one another a deeper level
it's not to say that the united states
microsoft shouldn't go and buy the
united states
side of tick tock and and that the
beijing bike dance
should or should not sell it it's just
it's
deeper than that it's way deeper than
that
though the economics are a layer
below the true spiritual
gnosis of what the true nature of
reality is
and the more that these major fortune
500 companies
the presidents and congresses around the
world silicon valley hollywood
beijing all of these places in the world
the more that they s they go
into the depths of understanding the
kingdom of god within
and the fact that we are all diversity
in oneness
and the true nature of reality the less
we'll have all of these issues come up
in the first place
we are having this issue come up about
tik tok
it's analogous if you look at tsa and
the transportation security
administration
the way that you have to go in there and
it's massive lines
it's massive security everybody's
getting scanned
nobody trusts each other to fly across
the planet like that
it's the same style of thinking the more
that we awaken ourselves to the true
nature of reality
the less we will need to have all of the
crazy
geopolitical insanities where we don't
trust each other
we have to awaken so that we can create
a more robust social fabric
where we trust each other
it's happening whether you like it or
not the evolutionary
pacer is moving towards enlightenment
and once we become more enlightened we
will not have these
geopolitical monkey politics issues
we will be able to have a more a better
and more robust
and more cohesive and interdependent
conversation with each other about the
technologies
it's the same style of thinking for
china we're going to put up this massive
firewall we're going to create a
pressure cooker function for all of
these tech entrepreneurs to build
the tech solutions in china here's the
thing
it's interesting to put different
entrepreneurial combinatorics from
around the world
what would it be like if brazil or
russia or china or
india or germany or pakistan or wherever
decided to make their own style if
tiktok for example became
open sourced and then pakistan created
their
own version of open source tik tok in
pakistan
right and maybe there was a way to still
give
creative contribution based on
intellectual property
to that initial creators of the open
source material
there's all of these different more
enlightened architectures
for the design of technology across our
planet that we have yet to tap into
because we are still in the egotistical
and in the service to self mentality
so we are waking up to the new
combinatorics and the new creative
processes
where you can take something like one of
these massive technological
beautiful solutions that is being used
across the planet for creativity and
whatnot
and you're able to potentially even at a
global level at a geopolitical level
you are able to have discourse with the
founders of this intellectual property
and say things like hey guys
how can we decrease the amount of people
that are being distracted
that are not able to achieve their goals
because they may not have the
self-discipline yet there will be a
component of ai coaches soon that helps
people with their self-discipline
but maybe there's a way to put up the
little notification that shows up after
five minutes of tick-tock use that says
that hey
were you by chance focused on a project
would you like to
exit out of tiktok right now and so if
you have these global conversations you
can do things like potentially even say
okay tick tock
now we what we want to do is we want to
create an indian version
of of tick tock locally so open source
that will pay you
a certain amount of or royalty for that
process potentially
and we will natively uh understand right
the facial recognition
you know these are the young people in
your country that are maybe between the
ages of 10 and 20
so the idea is that you would actually
want the facial recognition and all
these data insights around their
creativity
you would want to have that data
natively in your country
there are much better combinatorics than
what we have now
and we have to wake up to that the more
enlightened we become the more we'll be
able to work together more cohesively
that's that's pretty much it i mean
that's really the ethos
and the central pillars of what is going
on
in the the mainstream technology sphere
and we have to be very very
understanding that the more awakened we
become
the more we have inclusive stakeholding
and the more we have inclusive
stakeholding the more we
see our fellow brothers and sisters
across the country
and the planet as needing the same
basic needs as we do needing
the same basic needs as we do in order
for our gifts
to fully shine and thrive
and it's so simple guys it's so simple
bio mimic the way that nature works
with humans and our economic flourishing
the more we awaken the more we realize
this and the more we prosper faster
remember that thank you everybody for
tuning in
greatly appreciate it i'm very excited
for you to
let this stir up on a on a deeper level
embody some of these
main principles especially inclusive
stakeholding and
our future in that regard that's the
central part of
our big synthesis thank you for tuning
in
let me know what you think in the
comments below on this
brief bit and i love you very much i'm
super grateful for everybody that's been
continuing to
be a part of this community and support
what we're doing as we uncover the
nature of reality synthesize science and
spirituality
dive deep into the nature of metaphysics
and consciousness
we are at the edge baby
we are at the edge nobody's doing it
like us
nobody's doing it like us and so
we're all here early we're all here
early for the big awakening
i love you very much thank you thank you
couldn't happen without you
love you thank you peace
you